el padre de esta joven hondureña murió
por falta de atención médica en el
pasillo de un centro de salud hasta
donde fue llevado porque no encontró
cupo en los hospitales que se encuentran
colapsados por la emergencia del cob y
de 19
fui a varios hospitales públicos y
ninguno me lo quisieron atender luego
fui a hospital privado igual me decían
que no había cupo en ninguna del
hospital lo único que mencionaba que no
había cupo después decidí ir a un centro
de salud y ahí me lo ingresaron pero
ninguno de los doctores me lo quisieron
tocar en ningún momento a mí me decían
que yo hoy te darás por familia no me le
quisieron dar los primeros auxilios ni
nada aunque yo le pedí le rogado que por
favor que él fermentaba muriendo para
resolver la crisis sanitaria el gobierno
de honduras con con siete hospitales
móviles a turquía por 47 millones de
dólares pero de acuerdo a
investigaciones del consejo nacional
anticorrupción el costo real de los
hospitales es de 14 millones de dólares
por lo que consideran que hubo
sobrevaloración en la compra
además sólo dos hospitales han llegado
al país y aún no funcionan aprovechó hoy
la oportunidad para solicitar a la
procuraduría general de la república y
hay veces h que puedan conjuntar toda la
información para poder analizar los
incumplimientos en el contrato de los
hospitales que ya están en el país y los
otros hospitales que todavía falta que
lleguen por su parte el gremio médico
hizo sonar las alarmas ya que como
prueban estas fotografías tomadas
durante la investigación del ministerio
público parte del equipo médico
entregado con los hospitales viene en
mal estado mire estos hospitales según
lo que nos han dicho
1 y son cosas que ya se investigaron y
hay suficiente documentación venían con
material que era no solamente de segunda
que era material de desecho ya ni
siquiera bueno en un equipo de en buen
estado era basura prácticamente lo que
venía en los contenedores y mientras
esperan que los hospitales móviles
entren en funcionamiento los enfermos o
sospechosos por kobe 19 acuden a los
centros de triaje instalados
provisionalmente por el gobierno para
paliar la crisis sanitaria que atraviesa
el país el segundo en centroamérica con
la mayor tasa de letalidad por la
pandemia